okay so Oh whatever okay good
all right so nice
by the way when I resize this what's I
don't quite understand what's happening
here so I see there's a this is by
default resizing no how does how is this
resize that the image size it is not
controlled the GUI has bugs plus as we
discussed it's not it's not going to be
efficient so that's still we're gonna
fix all the bugs including the default
size behavior and so forth and I what
what is the default size bear I mean
this thing tracking the window size
seems ok but I said that by default but
we definitely need to be able to do
other things yeah I my I was thinking we
will go with the same defaults as for
the image objects if if the video is
larger than the width of a window we're
gonna limit to the size of the window
for sure and if the video is smaller
we're gonna stick to the video science
and and you can set the size using image
size okay or using dragging yes yes yes
ok good and the dragging okay fine
all right so okay so how do I take so
let's say I call this V V V equals this
okay so what do I do now - so you're
saying there is an audio track does the
goat have an audio track this one does
yes you then hear it as you were playing
I'm not set so that I've become a beacon
set this so that we can hear it
let's see
[Music]
okay now it's sharing computer sound
okay so how do I get the audio for this
if I just say audio of vvv do I get it
um I do not think so all you of that
file your dad that seems like a sensible
request yep
okay if I do audio of that file - I
guess that should work
bending bugs but yes why is it taking it
so long is it doing some big conversion
thing or is it term possibly oh this
might be some can you really ate that
that might be the good timing out for
some weird reason yeah it shouldn't be
doing any conversion see that it's still
linking to the same mp4 it's just gonna
be taking the first audio track that it
finds and that video file okay so if I
were to say something like audio where I
want to do audio plot of that
units
seconds seconds okay all right that's
pretty cool so though it's a stereo
audio is that correct okay um okay so
the first question here is
tract audio tracks subtitle track so for
example here if I said subtitle how
would I get what are you saying how do I
get r7o is that options
I understand but but I don't understand
what their options to import that say
what which audio track to which so with
empty once you asked for import of a
video file comma framerate and different
video tracks could have different frame
rates we thought about doing some kind
of a supplement specification to say I
want the first track or fifth track but
that's very annoying because most of the
times especially with video tracks
people only have one of them yeah yeah
I'm totally confused here what we're
talking about is I do import from the
file right yep and this file I I don't
understand what this track thing is is
is this saying I want to what is it
trying to say I want to pick out the
audio so that then give me an element
that's just called audio track right
yeah but what if you want a video object
we just the second audio track but it's
a full video object
from the import yeah some kind of posh
Limca like not importing all of the
Turks that I exist in the file well I
mean don't we have a multiple elements
mechanism for that right sorry go ahead
shadi go by let's let's maybe take
another example image image list element
of import assume you want to take frames
a hundred two hundred and ten with an
image list element from the second video
track okay what happens that we have is
either say image list in a list you say
image listen I don't think it's the
right approach I think by the time
you're doing things at that level of
detail you should be using the video
object you should not be trying to get
it through some backwards you know
specification through the import
elements
so I'm saying by the time you're doing
that since it is of no cost to say you
know attach this video object to this
file
then you know creating a video I mean I
would have thought that's why you should
put this stuff but I'm very good mean
well I joined by attaching a track to a
video I'm saying that we do this and
okay what do you do with an image if you
only want to see one channel of the
image if you want to see the relative
separate color colors separate image
comma R right right so I think we should
do the same kind of thing here I think
this is an actual action I mean I think
you should be able to import an audio
track I mean you know importing audio
track seven I mean most videos that's
not the story right most videos it's one
video track one audio track a subtitle
track for most videos yes I think all
the consumer cameras that's what they
generate on YouTube want for instance
you get a lot of videos that have
multiple audio multiple subtitles very
few of them have multiple video tracks
okay fine
well so then to me your your I mean if
you want to get audio track - I don't
know what what our typical syntax would
be for this whether it's something like
this I don't know I don't know what we
typically do for import elements like
that that's that's a typical thing to do
yes okay fine so that seems just fine
now what's the issue so there is another
usage for these options though that is
pretty important for the various
processing functions they tell a
function what to apply what will be
applied on I understand that but my
question is okay so there's two cases
one case is you are separating it out
okay let's talk about the let's talk
about images if you want to apply
specifically to the red channel in an
image how do you do that we we don't
have any function as to do that yeah we
I think we never wanted to process it
happens but it's rare enough that we did
then introduced the phone right so in
the in the
video case what are you telling me that
there is processing that you want to do
on an audio track for example that you
want to sort of feed straight back into
that video it's like a map where you're
you know a map at where you're mapping
at that audio piece is that right
exactly yes and that's common why is
that common
so you end up having I don't know a
translation a speech translation of an
audio track in another track and it's of
its noisy you just want it so you dubbed
it into I don't know Mongolian or
something and you and that and you want
to process the Mongolian dubbing but you
don't want to process other stuff is
that what you say yeah yeah okay so
that's the thing we're in the whatever
the video map
which
normally video map is taking what you've
got in the video applying a function and
returning the results but what you're
saying here is it's a video map act that
wants to map inside the video correct
returned many elements the video you
want to leave unchanged like Matt
except that it's video a ploy did you
applaud those names we never finalized
but we can go back to it but yes so
you're changing one track leaving the
other things either untouched or you can
set them to none so one other setting
that is not listed there for instance
you can say subtitle track goes to none
basically remove all over
no wait a minute we're confused here
okay there are several different things
going on first thing is you're doing an
import and you don't want to bring in
everything you just want to bring in a
sub part right that's right it's number
one okay
case number two which I don't think is
the same case you want to operate you
know function being applied
on you want to direct it at one part of
the video while leaving the rest
unchanged correct yeah okay another
thing you might want to do is to pull
out the subtitle track do something
completely different to it but not
reassemble it into the video correct or
you might want to take a completely you
know you might want to write your own
subtitle track running it through a text
translator or something and then inject
that into the video even though there
has been no subtitle you know you you
want to add a Mongolian subtitle track
even though one wasn't present before
and so you want to be able to inject
something new into the video correct I
don't think we have this functionality
okay but we're gonna need that yes it is
a continent that function probably some
syntax in export could handle that I
don't think that's the right place for
it I don't think we should be doing
these things externally I think look I
think the cases that we have here are um
you know okay so importing partial stuff
okay we've got applying functions to
partial stuff and we've got inserting
new stuff right correct yep
okay so I think those should all be I
want to make sure that we let's let's
take a look here
let's just do a quick scan of these
things before you get sucked back into
this okay yes I mean to me there's a
very clear story here for some things
okay so I mean clearly this is a fine
thing to do you know clearly subtitle
track is a fine thing to do and so on
right now presumably the subtitle tracks
are named is that correct
they could have names they could have
languages or they could be just number
okay
whatever okay fine so that's all we're
going to use okay wait a second we gotta
use it on language entities for this
sure
do we know how that how that how are
they named officially in videos I
believe it's it's not very much
sanitized Rebecca or color
also don't think it's standard are
standardized FCC so it's just actually
under names this step basically it's
just a text field and they don't use the
en and all that kind of you know they
don't use these ISO names and things
I think I've seen those Rebecca you can
comment on that
hello Rebecca
find your mute button no you're not
muted I I don't know she hasn't been
very much into video we we asked her to
help us coming so she's here
yeah Rebecca I'll try to on me
you
hello I mean she is unmuted but a
beautifully some things are not working
okay yeah but you may not know I
understand let's find out it let me just
point out one thing that is gonna be
backwards incompatible and annoying with
what you're suggesting now the image
list element that I was pointing out for
instance for a quick time and ABI that
we supported if you set image list comma
one it always returned the first frame
and now image list comma one the one is
gonna refer to the first video track no
another no it's not no no why would it
oh because you're saying it will be a
different track it's gonna be a video
track come on what are you doing okay
what what I'm saying is look image list
presumably defaults to the main video
track
I think poor Rebecca is having is
fighting with her audio is it working
now it is now we can I change nice to
hear from you right do you know the
answer to the question I think that it
is part of the metadata specification I
don't so
that would depend on the specific type
subtitle encoding whether you can get
that language I assume it would be
available even know whether whether
there is a standardized way of referring
to languages probably not okay let's
let's let's assume there isn't but but
um but we should obviously translate I
don't know what we do with with our
entities that's a separate problem okay
so what I'm suggesting here if you say
this then you will just get the image
list from the main track now will you
two want to get the image list from a
subsidiary track I don't know what
syntax to use for this I mean I think um
I guess that's where the option proposal
came for exactly this kind of situation
can you can you just complete this to a
list of image lists comma hundred which
used to return the hundred frame I know
that's right that's that's what it
should do either why it's the hundreds
rather than the first hundred I would
have thought it should be a take spec
where that will be in a separate list to
return just a hundred one
did you see what I'm saying
I would expect that would be take of the
think on 100 and this would be just the
hundredths frame and that I would I
would think that it would I would think
that it would return something with
spans and stuff like this but now that
they're as Carlo says the video track
option was proposed to tackle this
problem so that that number is always
okay well what I would suggest I don't
agree with that I I think what I would
do here is something like this I would
do video video track 1 comma image list
or something I mean this is an obscure
syntax but that's the kind of thing I
would do
you
I mean I guess it is obscure yeah if we
are convinced that this kind of workflow
is not something particularly common
then probably fine but I'm not sure but
that doesn't look that bad to me seems
like this would work fine and you might
be able to
you could probably remove that list we
didn't have 100 there but I don't think
this workflow is our recommended
workflow I think it's get it into a
video object and then process it sure
okay then video frames is the function
that you proposed we are developing that
basically is also extracting partial
stuff maybe we can quickly look at that
as well and see if we need the option
video track in it or no look I don't
think that's the right way to do it and
you know to me and maybe I'm wrong here
but to me it by the time you're getting
frames why don't have a function like
color separate that separates the tracks
but you rarely hear about frame number
10 from all of the tracks so I don't
know that I know that's it so I mean but
extracting the enth track and just
that's the result not an option to the
video in other words if you say extract
the enth track you get a new video in a
new file with only that track oh so that
is that is potentially problematic
because there is a very expensive
operation
- just take separate out one track is
gonna be very expensive but we went wait
a minute that so is that true for audio
as well no okay what does it mean to
have different video tracks what you're
suggesting sound to us as if you're you
want us to create a new file only with a
specific video track well that requires
data hold on hold on hold on when there
are multiple video tracks is that
because somebody had a camera with
multiple eyes in it and things is that
what causes you know necessarily you
could construct a video from using
different video tests using doesn't it's
very rare
okay but let me ask the question again
people have multi ID cameras what is the
thing that they get I would assume a
file that contains multiple video tax
that's why I don't know let's find out
okay um okay so okay bat backing up so
your point is it's much easier to have
an overlay that says consider only this
track okay
we're dealing with the corner case here
this case of multiple videos we don't
even understand what it shows up so I
don't think that's the thing to really
worry about the audio case is much more
interesting we already know how to peel
off a you know so the issue is if you
say audio of a video object there's a
question of which audio track you get by
peeling it out of the video
am I making sense do you get Mongolian
or do you get the Russian or what do you
get okay um and so that's the thing we
need to figure out and
now to get subtitles out of a video
there's a question of what is the
peeling off function that would get you
I mean because that that operation does
this does this goat video have subtitles
I don't know I don't think so yeah um
okay but but fundamentally what is the
subtitle track is it just running text
or does it have time markers and things
in it it has thanks thumbs yeah what
format would we bring the subtitle track
in in this is a very raw format called a
SS and we're not doing anything with it
at this point we just allow for users to
import it as raw as it is or transport
it to other okay so I mean ultimately
whatever dire ization we're gonna do
with audio that is going to give us back
a tagged you know sequence a tag time
series of you know a was talking here B
was talking there that's the same type
of thing I would assume that we would
want to turn the subtitle track in -
yeah it's an interval there has a value
that is a text okay and do we know what
that symbolic format is yet
for in
I think some type of us know we up what
about for dilation we don't have divers
ation yet we are doing single speaker
matching in recognition I think
something like we propose for
annotations is gonna make sense it's
gonna be region of interest with some
annotation being the name of a person
okay so let's go ahead and do the
following but let's try to invent that
symbolic format for the you know die
Erised speech and subtitle tracks okay
and I mean we're not going to do that
right now but let's why don't you guys
come up with some ideas for that sound
reason okay let's go let's go back over
here so your issue here is I want the
frames but I want to extract see what
what also bothers me is you know it's a
big deal whether you're extracting you
know from camera one or camera seven
it's not just a detail I mean if all the
cameras were looking in the same
direction maybe it's a detail but you
know it could be completely different
stuff and to me it's very weird that an
option is defining where that comes from
I mean it seems like something where you
should be saying yeah I mean I'm a
little confused by that so I can't agree
more Steven but as you see the track
selection index is gonna become in the
way whenever you want to get to that
time spec or in the next spec so you
always have to say a 1 comma something
for what I'm sorry for almost all of
these import video frames video so you
have to specify the track index before
the time index and that's that's
basically why we proposed that but
you've already told me that video tracks
are really rare things so okay let's
keep going I'm not sure about this okay
so this we've agreed on these these
pieces right video frames video comedy T
so the issue that we have had everyone
that we've shown this kind of simplex is
since there's essentially the parts in
text that is always interpreted okay
this will give me the frame at time DG
all right did we not come up with a
different approach to do okay this
particular thing of give me
you know a kind of I mean I'm thinking
about the actual use okay so like these
live streams okay let's say we wanted to
get thumbnails from these live streams
to me the useful thing is once a minute
once every two minutes whatever I just
want to get what roughly happened yeah
so you that would be easily achievable
we'd like the penultimate usage your
home wouldn't be I mean what would you
say you know zero comma minus one no we
don't even have a - you just do the span
without putting in the arguments right
yeah that's really colon semicolon
that's really obscure h40 or whatever
kind of shorter would decide is sensible
if any I just don't think this is a good
idea I think this is the common case I
think when people want video frames this
is the thing they want
I mean what do you want that to do with
a single argument gasps a single image
okay what if that's a quantity goes a
single image at that time
or what kind of been super yeah we could
support a time quantity or a frames
quantity for example
frames is a unit I gets interpreted as
in the independent unit okay why don't
you talk to the units of people because
we might have she wanted as a unit okay
I don't know how they deal with you know
queries per second and things like that
I think that may actually be a unit
which has conversions you also suggested
a frequency as the unit and maybe maybe
it is that gonna make you happy no no
it's not no it's not well have you got
the rest of video frames implemented
yeah it's in a branch I can show you if
you want
I put in unity put in your version of
tea okay I don't even understand how
that could possibly work because
normally if it was a well okay you're
saying it's a party specification yeah
all right okay put in your version okay
sorry I didn't understand no put in the
version that okay what the word thing
you want okay yes at the moment it is
implemented as you proposed and all you
can change it okay I understood put it
in your P like in a cup of tea and some
you should run your speech recognition
stuff on anyway um okay
Carl and our livestream is mentioning
the SRT format for subtitles I do not
know what that is that is a sidecar file
I asked cm right answers for community
subtitling that is not included in the
video file itself I'm not sure how we
handle that at the moment well okay but
so the issue would be to convert that
into the same symbolic representation
and then the question is to inject it
into a video file
okay and our subtitle support is going
to be very poor 12:1 yeah but we're
gonna be looking at all of those
trim you know what is audio trim do
it just streams the audio just take
exactly like this usage here okay
and really you're going to have seconds
with with the the integer there as
opposed to frames common case well ok
then what are you doing here are you
doing seconds are you doing frames same
second second
you really don't want to keep track of
your framerate and so forth to ask for
the index of the frame fair enough okay
that's exactly what we have done with
audio so I think it's far as consistency
it makes more sense okay all right video
map what is that okay so video trim and
those options like audio track video
track so I'm not sold on those options
yet I want to come back to those options
okay video map applies a function on
each frame
okay what if I want to apply only to
every tenth frame then you can use video
block map that is essentially block map
but but it's not blocked Matt because
block map takes all the frames every
time you feed it to the function it's
taking that whole list of frames as
opposed to taking just the enter for
every nth frame so you can specify it
right the window size and the offset so
if you specify a window size of one and
an offset can I see the docs for these
is this is there and not in there I'm
gonna unfuse a lot today and tomorrow
both video math and video block map
returned a time series of results so
this is not function if you think this
was going to transform your video every
tenth frame of the video this is not
video applies that so I'm saying I want
to extract every tenth frame and so wait
a minute if I just said identity okay so
if I said is video frames the equivalent
of video block map
let's see two partitions with offset
the video friends what is the partition
of video frames is that a list of video
frames yes so video block map of three
seconds or something would would feed me
in you know hundred and something frames
so f would get as an argument a list of
a hundred and something frames correct
right okay
is that syntax for duration offset is
that the same as block map
it's different from partition there no
it's its duration come off said as a
sequence of two arguments I think you
commented on that last time as well it
so let's not put it in a list here if it
block map doesn't do that and partition
doesn't do that why would video block
map do that I'm trying to think
Carlo maybe you remember did we have an
idea for a for for another argument
there in video block map you know what
we we can't change this okay okay this
is this is just has to work this way
okay and I would not call it duration I
would call it n here because it's n
frames so again here we are interpreting
a number as a time
and again you can specify your actually
call our livestream makes the following
good point what if you have a webcam or
a traffic camera that's taking a picture
only every minute well then the frame
rate will be very very low I guess no
but then you're gonna get a nonsense
when you ask for something in in seconds
look if this thing is giving you frames
if the function f is giving is being
given a list of frames the natural thing
here is the number of frames it's going
to be given because otherwise you're
gonna get the thing being fed a thousand
frames you know in other words what do
you expect this video block map
processing to do it's gonna take a few
frames at a time and do something to
them okay sure okay so essentially what
you're saying is we have both usages
using differentiate they're using
quantities essentially you want the
default number could be interpreted as
number of things I think so
shall I really think so I mr. own
opinion here
okay as long as we are consistent in all
of these because I'm sure I'm not sure
that we necessarily want to be because
in video frames okay first of all okay
this is so confused okay video frames
the name says frames oh right
let's use frame numbers if it the name
says frames I kind of agree with there
and then in that case two 1s panel 1-1
with a step makes sense as well four
frames yeah but I mean you should be
able to do the mixed case one minus one
one minute
yeah yeah those already super food okay
so I don't know whether things like you
know random webcams correctly timestamp
in other words for instance you know
things that take rare pictures do they
timestamp them or do you just get the
pile of frames
mostly I think I love frames okay okay
fine so let's make frames that our fault
okay I think I told you there are
extensions to exit that companies like
Google are suggesting that have metadata
per frame for videos things like geo
positions and time stamps and so forth
but that's not yet a very common
practice and that exhibit extension is
not standardized either I understand so
we can't necessarily read it yeah okay
okay
okay so you're gonna do an n comedy or
and come off sir sure for video block
map and video map
you
you
okay
you
so what does this comment here about
video time series Matt you didn't like
the name video math those are other
suggestions you have we never finalized
that me okay
hmmm I mean we are using things like
file system map which return a different
sort of
keying scheme - the way
you
yeah um
are you guys really happy with video map
as a name I mean I just think it's a
little obscure because what it is doing
is mapping frame by frame but I guess
you know by the time you have image
apply that's that's applying to
individual pixels and things this is
consistent with that yeah my my only
concern is that I'm sure we are all
going to confuse video map and video
apply one of them is returning a time
series the other one is a another video
and I don't think the names are distinct
enough yeah fair enough
what does block map video block map
returns a time series as well
what do we do if there isn't any if
there aren't any times I mean I don't
understand how we return a time series
of what we know as frame numbers
wait but we do have a frame rate right
do you have a frame rate what where do
you get the thin mate from it's stored
in a metadata
question does a webcam that takes a
picture every and maybe that just
doesn't do that maybe that's just a
series of images not a video so I mean
if it takes a picture every one hour but
then it produces and then you then it
stirs them in a video the video could
have a framework a frame rate of 24
images per second right just like a
time-lapse and that would be the actual
frame rate that we various uses okay
fair enough
steer the factor it takes an image every
15 minutes doesn't really matter or is
not relevant yeah
so
question is should this be video map
time series or some such other thing so
of the two options that you had in there
suggestions I did like the video frames
map slightly better than video time
serious man
seems a bit sure it spells exactly out
what the head of the output is but
I don't think it makes the operation any
cleaner clearer
well will you frame my scene well I
don't understand it video frames explain
why video frames is going to give a list
which it is right yeah that should be
called video frames list
they see a point I don't have a good
answer to this like it was hold on hold
on let's look at this so one possibility
is that um we call it video frames list
which is very clear what it does or
video frame list
um which will be more consistent with
our usage video frames list or video
frame list and then maybe of frames is
explicit enough for what that is well
not if we have another thing called
video
Crave's Mack yeah it's not gonna work
because by the time we have video map
returning a time series this returns a
list
you
okay so the operations are oh boy okay
video filter feeds back into the video
correct
idiot case a new video video apply does
what all so that there was a video
that's crazy
what does image apply do it returns an
image right
you know that video time series gets a
time series from a video by applying a
function f
you
which is what it does and has nothing to
do with map as such because map does
none of those things map would
well he applies the function to a list
of images it maps a function of a list
of images right do we think we're ever
gonna generalize that video time series
to also take into account pieces of
audio and subtitle so that the function
f takes a bunch of video frames and the
buffer of audio track
yeah I had why not that seems like a
good thing to do how would we do that I
mean I think this name is feather than a
video frame man hold on hold on hold on
hold on that what you're saying is that
that it one thing is f of image right
but another possibility would be F of
some kind of you know video buffer yeah
and then audio or something or or is it
a sub is is it rather a sub video that
you will be giving here F of some some
sliced video no I think what you have
below is what we have been thinking
about an association of video pieces all
your pieces and so forth okay but then
how would you specify which of these the
F is getting
so f is FF II in this case could be
taking slot video buffer slot audio
buffer
I understand that but how is that
consistent with this usage here Oh what
F is getting yeah yeah
you
so I mean this is in this form video
time series
mean to me
let's see what what's this argument now
this argument is the what is the next
argument it's the number of frames is
that right that you get no what is the
next video mark doesn't have it the
argument I think
okay well so so we've got what we've got
here potentially combining video blocked
map and video map his video time series
which has an F a video and then what
food the F is going to be fed
because what you've got to specify then
is you know the feeding instructions for
F if you if you saw what I mean and
those feeding instructions could be give
me the you know n frames okay so that
those instructions could be you know n
frames they could be DT time offset or
they could be don't give me n frames
give me this whole pile of stuff I'm
making sense so this is still not
covering the case of a video block right
where you get a or that is included in
your video before well what a video
block map is n frames at a time isn't it
yes oh sorry I interpreted others and
frames in total and was confused no no
because this is right so this yep yep
that's fine do you remember that moving
map has this syntax it's there's slot
values is the same as slot one is flow
so I think distinguishing between @f of
image or F of association could be
explained with a similar okay but but if
I want to do this video time series only
on a certain part of the video how would
I do that I would have to specify that
part of the video see see to me there's
a rapper that is needed which both is a
track extractor and a time extractor
something exactly something that creates
a new thing and you well I don't know I
mean so so look what we need is
something and it could be video itself
and it could be that that what you're
doing is you're saying video of video
blah blah blah comma and then the
extractor which gives both the the you
know beginning and end times right that
could be track number you know beginning
and end times
and other things which give you
essentially a sub video a region of
interest in the video how are we doing
region of interest in in images
not in any way that you're suggesting
here we just crock the part of the the
interesting part of the image no I
understand up and in the specification
we could have a rapper that is a wrapper
around the image that says this image
like a rectangle could be used as a
bounding box around there no I'm saying
but you understand what I'm suggesting
here I'm suggesting that you put a
decorator around video that gives track
number and so on and then you fed feed
that decorated video into video time
series if you want to get the time
series of you know you know when did the
goat cross the road I only want the sex
section where it crossed the road it
sounds like you want essentially a video
to him that's inherit
doesn't really well you tell me whether
whether I don't know whether I mean so
video trim that isn't accessible right
like like masking specification of
something yes it's like a region of
interest in the video but video trim is
that an expensive operation video trim
that can be an expensive operation
depending if you're trimming at key
frames or not
if it needs a Ryan Cory at decoding and
when calling Dania it's a terrible thing
to do
okay so a rapper would be a much better
idea for like as an input for all this
processing function seems reasonable
either that or a masking option in all
these processing functions depending on
what I think this is a better idea
because I think you want to carry around
when the goat crossed the road the
section of the video wedding goat costs
across the road or whatever
and then do operations on all of those
not have to give a you know have to I
mean you you want to get that once and
for all you figure that out
by you know clever machine learning
whatever and then you get back that
thing now the question is what the video
thing it's selfing what what else do I
have in it something like video region
of video and then the specification
yeah I don't know I'm just no no I
understand I understand
so in video itself what are the it only
has one argument right yep correct
you
see I think that an interesting way to
do this would be
in a perfect world we would take like if
it was adoration we would take this and
we would somehow highlight the relevant
duration or some such other thing on the
player
Pacey right and either way you know what
you would want to do is to show the
beginning frame when the player first
comes up you would want to show the
beginning frame
of the region of interest right I mean I
mean there are two two aspects of this
so I'd say that we have this supper it
has two roles one is to affirm the
processing functions were to extract
data from and the other one is to affirm
the GUI if if we want do anything
different with the GUI as you said
highlight something in there on that
purpose well for example if we want
caption presumably we're going to have
in the GUI a way of getting the captions
the subtitles yeah but okay assume we
have that then you might very well want
to pick which subtitles you want to get
yep if you know why then in your
notebook there should be a gear icon I
wasn't my nope oh yeah yeah that gear
icon which assets are going to come from
design if subtitles exist that's gonna
give you the option to switch between
them also the audio tracks okay
and video tracks video tracks yes
you
you
um just just one minor thing when it
comes to for instance exporting objects
that have these regions of interest
baked into them I am guessing what
you're gonna suggest is that we're gonna
export that region of interest call you
oil but I'm I'm not sure people expect
that all the time I don't know unless we
make it very clear that these so masking
for instance has mostly been used to
specify what locations to process and
that's not necessarily what you want to
use when exporting or saving well I I
don't always take it off but the
question is whether we have a wrapper I
mean I'm not really liking the idea of
CC one thing is let's say I know what it
should be called
oh yes this is a good name video
selection
that's similar to what we do in the in
the symbolic database stuff
so let me for a second try to argue
against this so you said this will be
the output of some expensive computation
you decided that this is your region of
interest with some whatever method
mm-hmm now
Vernie be just as easy to save this
output as an interval of a list of
intervals and then have a masking option
in all of the costs there will be
absolutely horrifying okay it's a really
bad idea just think about it I mean
you've got that you've got I'm selecting
Mongolian as my audio track etc etc etc
yeah you'd have to keep track of more
things yeah it's a total mess okay
however writing is finished okay I think
in that particular case I think you're
wrong you're often not but the UM no no
I mean I see a point yeah um okay so I
like this idea of video selection um so
then that would give you you know you
know team NT max here we could say
absolutely you know audio track well
what we could do here we could have
just say audiotrack now the question is
what makes it okay so what I would
suggest is
the
um if you explicitly say video of video
selection it bakes it in right it just
does that it makes it you know it
returns outlays it will export a file I
guess I would assume so yes yeah only
has things and you don't have the video
selection information and Merv just
because that is what the video is that
is correct
yeah that seems reasonable the only
objection that the the only point that
pure pointed out is that if you want to
do something like this then we need all
of the X we need first of all the file
name and a file extension pic though and
then all the export options such as
video encoding audio encoding and so
forth what are you talking about
for what to get yeah go ahead you're
creating a new file you're not replacing
your existing file that that the lower
case video is linking to
so you basically need a file name or we
can automatically pick a file name yeah
I'm sure you've got capabilities to make
automatic file names you don't know is
what happens in video to them or what
will happen in video tame and video
filter and all of those functions right
fine
and okay all that okay all the
properties could come from the video
itself as far as file name that the
container and encoding okay so video
selection then would be the can the
thing so for example when you
right so okay so then this the
solves a bunch of problems here so then
okay so let's try this out so video
frames over video produces this list of
frames
that's giving a list of frames video
time series is giving a time series I
mean this could be
this is very explicit
video frame list video time series you
can drop the part specification at this
point because you could just save it
ephemeris the video selection which part
specification from time one to time too
yes that's correct that would be a
better way to do it which would be how
about times
yellow so we get to use my DT final yeah
the problem is that the intermingling
that DT and the path specification was
bad but using one the other is okay I
think I think so too I think this is so
if you want a frame list
[Music]
now whether that defaults to frame
numbers - I think DT is the correct way
to default here and then you do video
selection of that and then the and then
the the range that you want it over I
like this and I really like being able
to carry around the selection
information yeah the other advantage of
that is that you we don't produce ease
less intermediate files yeah it's a good
reason to do it okay so for now video
selection you know it will be nice to
have a nice output form for video
selection but we could just have it sit
there with the video you know as a
symbolic thing that's what I was
thinking the first step would be like
injecting that knowledge in and all the
processing function and then your second
step include that into a GUI fine okay
so video time series F on video and it
is being fed notionally an association
um
this would be
you know block information here
do you want it you know how bigger the
blocks and the default is so that would
be
you know a frame count and that would be
a D frame so to speak
frame Delta right so that that's saying
how many frames to feed in to F at one
gulp
and that's saying a delta and if you
don't specify the argument you will get
a single inning of frame yeah a single
frame I think but now now
not a list of what yeah I understand
this year I understand the issue I'm not
so totally certain about that yeah I
guess so I hate it okay but I think the
way we could do it
I hate it I hate this is why we had to
separate I know but you don't want to
functions just to get rid of one list
yeah
I think this is okay think it's okay all
right so then video trim if you really
want to have the function have it but
you don't really need it anymore
because it's just video a video
selection
so the nice thing of video to him is as
I said we couldn't try to be more
efficient target fine do it so that's
not a problem not a problem okay so now
we've got video apply okay which is
which is doing what it's applying frame
by frame correct correct
honestly that's the thing that is much
more video map
I guess so because the the head is
preserved in input and output right why
did we call it image reply we were just
trying to avoid the name image map
because image mantis means something
different yes
I mean we could all
your frame map yep I would be her I
think that's actually good because I
think that
we could imagine a future world in which
we're actually gulping videos into the
little mini videos into this function f
you
okay video frame map ever video and
presumably it could have the same frame
count frame Delta as video time series
so yeah that is video filter and the
difference of video filter is that
instead it could apply a function also
to the audience of title track why don't
we do the exact same thing as video time
series with it same you know hash audio
track and so on hash audio this seems
reasonable that way we get a single
function there good this is a nice
design this is a confirm how did we how
how did we decide on not frame counts
specified is that a single frame or a
list of a single frame or we're not even
supporting that sorry when frame count
is not specified yes I think it's a
single frame not a list of a single
frame but little painful but I think
it's the right thing to do then if we do
that adds yeah with your frame map could
do the same thing exactly I mean reduce
to two functions yep okay another a
point I something bugs me about video
selection and I'm guessing we're gonna
be supporting video and the video
selection in almost all of the video
functions
it seems redundant okay and we maybe
work out a solution with some options
for video so it's not a good idea
because what you want to do is you want
to have video itself be a video right
I mean you don't want because what you
want to do is you want to actively think
about making a selection see what I'm
saying but you don't you want this to be
just hanging around as a symbolic
specification of a selection while not
actually burning it in as a video do you
see what I'm saying
as I said before I think the three
options here are one you keep your
information in separate variable to
dinner after and three creating a new
file right and creating your file you're
doing using video which is a you know
it's a it's a serious act so to speak as
opposed this is symbolic stuff which is
just fluff um okay let's confirm though
for video selection um
you
the UM the question of how you are
asking for particular I mean I I don't
know whether we want to go you know
options full of options here
you know audiotrack goes to one and
things I don't know
you
I mean clearly this is a useful thing to
just get the audio track what is the
syntax here and do you want just a big
association that tells you what which
parts of the video you want to select or
what how what's the right thing sir
so we have several things first of all
what what does video selection of video
we know further arguments mean just the
original video just the original video
select everything so if we specify
additional arguments what what does that
mean we drop everything except that
additional argument or do we specify the
things to drop I guess these are no we
do not specify things to talk especially
to keep that's why it's called video
selection as a perfect video D selection
okay so we need to select which track
for the three stock specification audio
video and subtitle and then we might
want to specify an interval which
probably should be common to all the
tracks
so so my proposal is that we have the
second argument be the time interval and
then for the dark selection we use
options possible or we could just say I
think the dooster should be independent
Oh everywhere whole thing video tracks
defaults okay so you might have now I
agree with the independence there so I
mean video selection a video you know
TNT max and probably just a tea there
would just be from the beginning of the
video um and then we could say video
tracks arrow none which will be the
somewhat rare case of extract just the
audio that would be equivalent to saying
audio of the thing audio tracks arrow
all or arrow you know 1 or arrow 2 comma
3 or whatever you want to do all the
names yep right I think there is nice
and ambiguous because then we can
document that no human case as video
selection of video comma all comma video
tracks goes to all etc etc yes
right and the VM if you want to kill one
of the tracks for whatever reason this
is what you do
sounds pretty reasonable to me yeah I
think this is going to those options are
plural so far we had them singular I
don't think it's right to have them
singular because I think that there
could be it suggests that there I mean
the whole point of having the option is
that there are multiple things to choose
between
and if there aren't then why use the
option uh uh alright so far we're not
gonna include them in important or
export but we probably look given that
we have these options we probably could
include them
why not
I mean there's a lot of cans of worms
there because there's remapping what if
you want to extract export this video
but you want to actually say I want to
call my subtitle track you know bill or
something what I'm saying I don't know
how you would do that
you
yeah I do not know I don't actually
probably spurt
probably the way you do that is by
giving those options to video itself as
opposed to to video selection
because video selection is telling you
what to select out of the video video
with the subtitle tracks would be
telling you you know would be in a sense
saying this is what I want in the video
except that our video object now doesn't
have an option called subtitle try but I
understand but I don't think we should
let's let's not do that right now I mean
we don't need that like I would prefer
that okay um
so you asked for that second thing in
there and and that's or no you you
wanted many manipulate animate and all
those things and you wanted to directly
get their video object so that's not we
have now and that's not that's it there
these are what we have into a1 okay but
but what I'm saying is and I don't care
how you do it you can create an
intermediate file which is what I assume
you will do but video over manipulate
should just work but then again we are
introducing all the export functions
that we have for exporting manipulates
to video files which include things like
controller I understand that I
understand that that look what I'm
saying is this particular thing should
just work but not take any options like
export does it gives it it would be nice
to give it a framerate and things but
it's not necessary but the point is that
then we would introduce those options
for video period and they wouldn't make
sense in any under the pace oh yeah it
fine then don't put them there I mean
this is our default video this is a
we're gonna give you a video of this
manipulate you know be happy so to speak
and then when you want to export it then
you might want to specify a frame rate
and things like this but the important
cases as far as I'm concerned of that
and video of animate
and probably video of list animate there
they're all manipulates at the end of
the day so okay fine um I mean that will
be very nice that that's a you know
that's something where yeah it's good
okay now and presumably in these cases
it will say not a notebook you know
choose to store it type thing you know
what I'm saying for the data that is
being put in an external local object
file it is a local object file isn't it
it's a file not a local object why not
no particular reason I guess okay just
because expert doesn't put things in I
know because export is exporting it to
where you want it exported to where as
this is I mean it should be in the local
object store didn't we agree that we're
gonna put these on there dollar rule
from the new thing user document
directory I thought that's what we
agreed on why why why isn't it going in
the local object store I mean those
sorry what Charlie's talking about is
all the output of the processing
functions like video apply and I know
but I'm saying if it's something you
want to keep around um you know it
should go in the local object store
you
why wouldn't it that's
objects tour is for
and you know we'll have you know
functions for watching how big it gets
and like this Steve and we discussed
this in a different meeting why do you
think this is any different from all
your capture
we agreed that speech synthesizer audio
capture are gonna start pooling files on
their dollar
I remember that discussion I can't
remember why I got talked out of the
local object store can you remember
let's revisit this with an explanation
either way there may be or it but you
can do whatever you want for this
version sure okay I but I'd like an
explanation for why it's not going in
the local object store because it makes
sense to me um
I mean this dollar video encoders
decoders that's kind of you know it's
kind of a mess to have all those things
in that why do we really need all that
couldn't we have something go ahead well
basically for I think for users access
to see what they can look this this
whole very mechanism of you know import
formats export formats and so on we need
a better way to do this we need
something that's closer to the entity
store mechanism as a way to store all of
this meta information and it's like the
crazy thing about not knowing I mean
listen I've ended up too often like for
example here's an example I wanted to
try all possible visualizations of a
graph okay so I literally copy-paste the
column from the documentation of
possible graph layouts but that's crazy
yep I mean we've got a whole bunch of
these things where we essentially have
or you know the list of musical
instruments for sound objects yep you
know those are just crazy that we have
to do that and I think these these
internal discovery type things um
look let's get reminder remember we did
we created a tree sampling algorithm
data
that's that's yet another way of okay
let's get I understand so let's let can
we get a meeting set up it should be
part of the ILD series I guess I'm not
sure if it's oh the LCC series I'm not
sure which it it reminds me of the
standardized progress indicators meeting
will I notice we have tomorrow which is
an effort to standardize how we deal
with internal discovery like this
internal option discovery it's probably
the right title for and internal option
value discovery I guess um let's try and
standardize it and get rid of all these
dollar you know whatever variables okay
question from a number of comments on
our live stream here um
the I noticed that Carl our live stream
is called it video frames list as
opposed to video frame list um and I
wonder what the right thing is there you
know I have to say I think video frames
list may be better because less
thoroughly conveys the fact that there's
multiple it's a list of okay I guess
oh I don't I don't know this is I don't
think my English is good enough
we have entity list edge list menu lists
and so forth
fine you know you're right you're right
that's singular it could be edges list
and it isn't it's edge list yeah um okay
question comment from sander video map
thread which takes multiple videos to
create things like picture and picture
why not that's very cool probably not in
draw one but it's a very sensible idea
the that is a cool idea
um I mean even non-accessible
picture-in-picture but just something
from two frames then there are there are
many questions that I guess well there's
a synchronization of frame rates it's
like that well one thing is compositing
of you know have a thing where you have
multiple you have a video formed from
four videos for example
the the thing that I usually refer to as
the Brady Bunch effect but Tim I'm not
sure that that that may be a timing out
it requires knowledge of a random TV
show that had died before I came to the
US but I'm aware of it for other reasons
um there if you look it up you'll see
what I'm talking about
um the
okay I think that's gonna basically
cover a whole bunch of functions that we
would like to have why collaging
multiple videos assembling them blending
them and things like that so no I I
definitely think we need that but again
no not not right now okay um sandir
comments on Wolfram language data as a
as a place to put these internal
discovery things I was thinking about
that I'm not sure if that's the right
place for it but it's a good thought um
Brian our live stream is asking how
would you insert an audio track or a
closed caption good question let's walk
through that I do not think we have any
workflow to do that at the moment how
would we do that I mean that's what we
were talking about again where we're
saying video see I could imagine
something where you do something like
like ad talk or something advocate
tracker well possibly or something like
this where it's just video yeah set of
rules oh okay just video export has it
export with the rules exporter element
can take image lists or a video I think
and then an audio and then I export both
into the same oh and principle what we
could do here is we could have a video
I'm not sure how this completely relates
to video I mean it seems reasonable
right having the video head take a list
of organizational video and something
else and just confusing you far with
those it seems like it's consistent I
mean because we could also specify a
particular video track you know it could
be video track 1 or video track 2 or
whatever so that seems more the job of
expert
well it really already does know but you
don't want to use export because you're
doing stuff the whole point is export is
you lost the game we're sending it to
something outside oh well I dunno our
video object needs to be based at the
moment on a single file yes I understand
that I understand I understand what
you're saying but I understand that you
are internally doing an export basically
to create a file ok what I'm saying is
that to the user it's like we're just
doing things with video objects the fact
that behind the scenes files are being
juggled is irrelevant
ok ok in
hmm okay I kind of like the list
specification slightly better but then
you are not allowed to name your talks
in a specific way which might well I
mean look the obvious way to do it is if
you do this and you do um you do named
arrow blah blah blah that would just
work but if that is a video object that
could have already a video track add an
audio track and a subtitle track right
so that name I'm not sure what that name
applies to I don't know either
this is I don't think there's a problem
we have to solve today this we're not
gonna agreed um it's clear there is a
way to do it okay let me just take a
quick look down here and then we can
wrap
understand what what video reflect I
mean isn't that
just a video frame map of image reflect
yep
I wouldn't have that I mean that seems
like a very obscure operation the one
thing that would be okay the one issued
where it would make kind of senses if we
could use ffmpeg filters to make the
operation more efficient if you just
what what sorry what
some ffmpeg tools filters I see that are
more efficient then well importing that
ADA mile
I mean maybe just have to look at do
compilation of yes this is one of the
frame we talked about like parsing the
function as they that's the input of
right I mean I think that's the future
anyway is to be you know we're running a
compiler and the compiler can do all
kinds of things and if it compiles to
ffmpeg whatever it is um you know cuz it
could one day compile to GPU operations
etc etc yeah okay thumbnail that is
important I mean that will be worth
having to me if you ask about these that
one just in terms of managing video
stuff that would be really useful so
that's good and probably an easy thing
for us to generate I mean look worst
cases we generate right now we generate
one from a keyframe or something um
video from a function well isn't that
I mean that is the whole graphics from a
function which is something separate
thing that we need to talk about this is
a play and a lock for video clay over
the function now you want really you
know put play of a function typically
creates audio samples you want a version
that creates video what's it gonna show
well if it's a graphics of a moving desk
or whatever
we need to talk about that that's a
complicated thing because that's like
object-oriented graphics stuff um
sorry let me just look at one more thing
here Oh video measurements yeah that's
an obvious kind of thing that's an
obvious thing that we'll need which will
be like image measurements that will
have a whole pile of gunk inside it pile
of wonderful stuff inside it perhaps
like audio measurements on your local
measurements we're gonna have two here
one is for the whole video one it is
local I see is it local or is it frame
based in which case it should be called
video frame measurements or is it not
necessarily frame oriented not good okay
something like loudness could be is
definitely not frame oriented it's it's
taking all your samples okay let us
think about it
fine no problem all right well looks
great Bob on our live stream is
commenting to be like to be able to
clean up old black-and-white videos and
colorize them that with the video map
and then you can apply the colorizing
neural network to there yeah although I
have to believe you can do it a lot
better if you can see multiple frames at
a time absolutely especially if you have
a Jeep you yeah you would just import
the frames throw it to the net
altogether and yeah let's said right
okay wonderful stuff if you have further
questions let me know otherwise I think
this is I think this was a substantial
uptick in the design of this video stuff
um and it looks like it's very easy for
you guys to implement so um and I will
send you these notes since I don't know
if checked-in has access to um this area
and I need to go have my lunch okay see
you later thanks on livestream - bye